Today, I’m going to be looking at a randomly
selected deck from one of my Patrons,
with this deck coming from Jovism. His deck’s
commander pairing is Erinis, Gloom Stalker with
a background of Street Urchin, and the first
thing I note about this pairing is that it
feels like two different commanders much more so
than most other background pairings. You know,
you’ve got a bunch of cases where the background
basically acts as an enhancement of the
commander—Baeloth but big, Burakos but he draws
some extra cards, Wilson but he’s a demon lord,
and so on. By contrast, Street Urchin pairs with
Erinis’ deathtouch to turn into a removal engine,
so the command zone effectively ends up offering
two entirely separate things—land recursion,
and removal. Let’s start by thinking about
the land recursion part—the most simple
usage here is using the ability to ramp with
evolving wilds type lands and harrow effects,
and indeed the deck is doing a good amount of
this. It also contains several different lands
with interesting sacrifice abilities,
as well as four artifact lands to fuel
Street Urchin. For the removal part,
the deck is running lots of artifacts
and creatures it’s okay with sacrificing,
as well as cards that generate tokens.
With these two things—land recursion and
removal—in its pocket, the deck is looking
to generate advantage in cards and mana over the
course of the game while keeping opponents in
check via its built-in creature removal as well
as a number of removal spells for artifacts and
enchantments. Once the board state is under
control and it has built up enough resources,
the deck then looks to win either byy
swinging with a board of big creatures,
or by playing a buff equipment and hitting its
blocker-less opponents with Erinis a few times.
Having laid out my understanding of what the deck
is trying to do, my next question is how is the
deck doing at accomplishing its goals? First
of all, the removal engine in the command zone
is pretty fearsome—at any point in time you can
pay 1 and sacrifice an artifact or creature to
kill an opposing creature. The deck packs 19 total
cards that generate creature or artifact tokens,
and 11 other artifacts and creatures that the
deck is either indifferent about sacrificing,
or actively wants to sacrifice. I want to
highlight a couple sac-fodder cards I find
particularly neat—Scion of Calamity is a nice
creature with myriad, and the tokens it creates
can either be sacrificed in response to their
damage triggers, when they’ve already gotten all
of their value, or before blockers are declared,
so that the deck can clear a path for Erinis to
dish out some commander damage. Another fun one is
Humble Defector—activate, sacrifice in response,
get them cards. Finally, Treasure Vault is a cool
option for resource-building—it can be sacrificed
on an opponent’s endstep and brought back each
combat step, allowing the deck to accumulate mana
and sacrificeable artifacts if the game is in a
lull and it doesn’t quite have what it needs to
win yet. Overall, the suite of sacrificeables
that the deck has seems more than adequate.
The number of ways to get lands into the graveyard
is also pretty solid—8 slow fetches, 7 other sac
lands, 10 discard effects, 4 artifact lands that
can get sacrificed to Street Urchin, 3 Harrow
effects, and a few other cards. The deck also runs
quite a lot of draw overall, including a whole
bunch of filtering, some more generic choices, and
a handful of things such as Keen Sense that pair
nicely with the commander. This draw, paired with
the deck’s healthy suites of cards supporting its
command zone, lead to the deck being able to jump
into its land-recursion-and-removal-based gameplan
with a high degree of consistency. The deck’s
ramp suite is particularly interesting to me,
in the sense that the only ramp card in the deck
that isn't specifically supporting the command
zone is Sol Ring. The deck could run dorks
to boost out Erinis a turn earlier or rocks
to boost the deck’s overall mana count going into
the midgame, but these options would eat up slots
that could go to making sure the deck has lands in
yard and stuff to sacrifice on board. The result
of this choice is that the deck operates with
a very consistent curve—Erinis played turn 3,
Street Urchin presumably played turn 2 or 4, and
whatever other utility plays needed to set up the
deck’s engines on other turns, with Erinis
ramping a land on the combat step of turn 4.
As far as winning the game goes, the
deck has a few buff equipments that
can let the commander kill opponents in
2-3 hits, a few big landfall creatures,
and a handful of other sizable creatures. On the
surface, this doesn’t seem like very much—can this
selection of stuff really win the game? Well I
haven’t played games with the deck myself so I
obviously don’t know for sure, but it follows
a principle I laid out in my wincons video,
which is that control decks can win games with
less powerful finishers than midrange decks,
simply because they generally have more time to
work with and less on-board resistance to worry
about. Once Gruul Control gets the game into a
soft lock, where major opposing threats are all
under control, hitting opponents three times each
with an adventuring Erinis is a win plan that I
could absolutely see being viable. Playing more
powerful cards to win is certainly an option,
but I could totally see an argument that if
the deck doesn’t need them, why play them?
Another area of the deck I can comment on
is the manabase, and with 21 green symbols
and 18 red symbols within the lands, I’d
call the manabase not great but passable,
and it’s certainly somewhat helped by the
deck having 9 instances of low-cost filtering
available at single red, as well as land recursion
in the command zone for single green. Finally,
I like that the deck contains several protection
spells since it’s so reliant on the command zone,
and I think this problem is also somewhat
helped by Erinis’ cheap cost and built-in ramp,
which make needing to replay them once or twice
not a big deal. The reactive part of the command
zone package, the removal, is also usable any
time both Erinis and Street Urchin are in play,
meaning that opponents will struggle to keep this
removal engine offline for long unless they’re
willing to throw a lot of pieces of removal at
the commander. Erinis is still naturally going
to be a weak point due to the deck being
heavily built around them being in play,
but due to the factors I mentioned I don’t
think it’s a crippling problem or anything.
Okay, I’ve gone through the stuff that I think
the deck either does well or does acceptably
at. If I had to sum up the biggest issue I
see with this deck, it’s actually mostly a
social one. This is a decidedly mid-power deck
in terms of its speed and how it wins the game,
but for a mid-power deck it’s brutally effective
at killing creatures, and there will naturally be
players at that power who aren’t thrilled to have
their board kept empty of meaningful threats the
whole game. So why not make the deck more powerful
to have it play at a level with more tuned,
cutthroat decks? The issue is that there
are several factors about this deck that
make increasing the power level difficult, and
to demonstrate this I’m going to explore a few
different potential improvement routes for the
deck and talk about where I think they fall short.
For one, what if we increase the speed of the
deck? Add some one mana dorks, or replace some
Evolving Wilds-type cards with actual fetchlands?
As I mentioned earlier, the issue with adding
faster ramp is that the deck’s choice not to run
ramp that doesn’t support the command zone is
part of what lets it jump into its core gameplan
with a high degree of consistency. If you start
replacing Harrow effects and treasure generators
with ramp that lets you get out Erinis on turn 2,
you’ll get Erinis triggers earlier, but you’ll
on average have fewer lands in the graveyard and
fewer tokens to sacrifice, negating some of that
increase in speed. I think ultimately efforts to
improve the deck’s ramp suite would end up a
wash, giving it occasionally more explosive
games at the cost of doing what it wants
to do less consistently. Actual fetchlands,
on the other hand, would likely make the deck
faster, but they alone won’t make the deck that
much better, and are also pretty pricey. Another
improvement route would be adding more protection,
since the deck relies heavily on its command zone
and thus has a pretty big point of failure. And I
wouldn’t mind a couple more protective cards,
but this is once again a bit tricky due to the
deck wanting to have as many slots as possible
devoted to making sure its command zone is able
to do what it wants to do—additional protection
comes at the cost of the speed and consistency of
the core gameplan. The deck’s colors are another
challenge—a lack of white or blue means that the
deck will struggle to deal with certain types
of removal, and this color pairing additionally
limits the amount of stack interaction the
deck is able to run to prevent opposing wins.
Destroying some key creatures and artifacts
might be able to slow down opposing decks,
but this is the sort of deck that will really
struggle to contain more explosive wins if it ever
falls a bit behind, making decks that win with
combos and noncreature means a tricky matchup.
This brings me to a third possible way to improve
the deck—improving its finisher suite. One option
for doing this could consist of adding a couple
gnarlier landfall creatures such as Scute Swarm
or Moraug, and another option would be adding an
infinite combo of sort sort, but both of these
approaches have problems. Adding the more powerful
landfall cards won’t improve the deck’s power
level that much as these are still threats that
require some time and setup to turn into a win,
and the plan of adding a combo to our
control deck to help it win before an
opponent plays a threat it can’t deal with kinda
conflicts with its identity as a control deck,
right? Obviously this is subjective, but in my
book this deck’s gameplan should be to outgrind,
not outrun—generating resources and stabilizing
the boardstate should be your focus, not rushing
to find combo pieces. Overall, there are ways
for the deck to bump up its power level a bit,
but the most concrete one starts with buying or
proxying $180 worth of lands for a two color deck,
itself a move that feels strange, and further
upgrading attempts might risk fundamentally
changing the identity of the deck in a way that is
less satisfying. Overall, I don’t think it’s worth
it to make major changes to this deck, and even
the handful of additions and cuts I would consider
are subjective choices, and still maintain the
middling power level of the deck. This deck’s
conundrum, where upgrading is hard but playing
at mid-power can feel weird, is one I find
familiar— it reminds me of a scrapped deck idea I
featured in a pretty early video on this channel.
A Child of Alara Maze’s End deck will likely
perform decently at a midrangy mid-power table,
but it’s a deck that will fall on its face in a
handful of matchups while creating a miserable
table experience in all of the other ones. I’m not
going to elaborate too much on that concept here,
but I threw a link in the description
if you want to hear my full thoughts
on the subject of running a heavy-duty
removal suite at a middling power level.
Though the principle is the same, Gruul Control is
certainly less severe than the Child of Alara deck
due to its removal being single target creature
removal rather than nonland permanent wipes,
and I actually think that fact gives it a valid
position at a lot of mid-power tables. As long
as people know what the deck is capable of
and to expect to get their creatures yeeted,
it can play into a flexible “archenemy”
dynamic, where the table tries to figure
out how much resources to spend suppressing it,
while also keeping in mind that fully locking
it out removes a roadblock for their opponents
to win with a creature-based wincon. This can
lead to some really cool gameplay—my Glissa
deck generally tends to play into a similar
dynamic—but it’s important to make sure that
the table is looking for that sort of gameplay.
It’s also a type of deck that should be played
sparingly, in my opinion. It can be fun to
occasionally pull out a deck that demands the
table’s full attention, especially if the table
is full of solitaire midrange, but pulling
out that type of deck too often can lead to other
people feeling like a side character in the four
player game they’re playing. This is the sort of
deck that’s fun to think and talk about to me
because it serves as an interesting case study
into the ways people relate to games they play,
and what people find fun. That’s all I have to say
about it, but you can check out Jovism’s deck in
the description, and let me know if you think my
analysis is correct or if you have a different way
you’d go with the deck. Also make sure to do all
the interactive things, liking and subscribing and
all that jazz. I also wanna give a shout out to my
patrons, both in general for giving me money,
and for submitting decks for the drawing. This
was a lot of fun, and I look forward to doing
more of these in the future. Alright, bye now.